this is the iPhone se3 and it just might
be the last one that Apple will ever
make and in my opinion that might
actually be a good thing but before I
get into explaining my take on this
whole ordeal check out this tweet from
one of the most reliable Apple leakers
out there Mecha quo says that apple is
going to cancel or postpone mass
production of the 2024 iPhone se4 and
why well there are a couple of different
reasons the first one is that apple is
getting consistently lower than expected
shipments of mid to low end iPhones like
the 13 mini and 14 plus on top of that
there are concerns that the full screen
design of the se4 will lead to higher
selling prices as well as concerns about
cutting unnecessary new product
development expenses during the 2023
Global recession and those reasons might
lead to the cancellation of the se4 now
some people say that it's a terrible
idea DF Apple does that because they
love the essay line but others would say
that it's actually a great idea well to
find out the truth we have to look at
what made the SE Line special in the
past as well as where it all went wrong
one of the reasons why people loved the
original iPhone SE was because at the
time the entire iPhone 6 lineup took on
a brand new design which was actually
controversial since a lot of people
believed that the old design was better
so the iPhone SC allowed people to stick
with the old iPhone 5S style design
while getting some new hardware as well
which is a win-win for those who loved
the old boxy design but now this is the
current iPhone SE 3 and unfortunately
it's lost its special feel for various
different reasons instead of the SE
being the boxy Choice it's now
unfortunately the only Iphone currently
for sale with the same rounded Edge
design that people disliked about the
iPhone 6 not only that but in a world
where the Android competition has full
edge to edge OLED displays for the same
price or less the SE comes with the same
old 4.7 inch LCD display and a very
dated home button and making everything
even worse MKBHD just released his best
smartphone camera of 2022 video and
something really important stood out to
me during the night mode portion of the
test out of all 16 phones that he tested
which all came out this year the iPhone
SE was by far the worst at night mode
because it's the only phone out of all
of them that doesn't actually have night
mode and if you're wondering why that is
it's not because of the chip since this
comes with the same a15 bionic chip
that's in the new iPhone 14. so why does
it not have night mode well the truth is
that that Apple intentionally left that
feature out to make the more expensive
models seem better and then adding even
more to the pain they raised the price
of the iPhone SE to 429 dollars so right
now potential buyers have the choice of
either spending 429 on an outdated SE or
600 for an iPhone 12 which is better in
literally every single way it gets Max
safe it gets rid of the home button it
gets much better cameras a much larger
OLED display better speakers better
battery life and more and believe it or
not I recently needed to buy a budget
iPhone for business use for one of my
employees so she can take phone calls
and guess what I bought an iPhone for
460 dollars and it wasn't the SE yes I
bought a fully unlocked iPhone 12 on
Amazon for 460 dollars just 30 bucks
more than the SE now I know no it's not
brand new but it's got Amazon's renewed
premium guarantee which has a few
important benefits most importantly it
comes with a one year satisfaction
guarantee so if you're not happy with it
you can return it within that one year
it's also guaranteed to have over 90
battery capacity as well as minimal
cosmetic damage which is not noticeable
when the device is held at arm's length
and on top of that it comes with a brand
new mfi charging cable and charger in
the box which ironically doesn't come
with a new iPhone SE from Apple or any
other new iPhone so to be completely
honest with a deal like that readily
available on Amazon you'd have to be
crazy to buy an outdated iPhone SE
especially heading into 2023 and one of
the main reasons I chose an iPhone 12
instead is that it has face ID which is
honestly the best form of authentication
ever put into a smartphone and that's
where the iPhone se4 was supposed to
come in it's rumored to have a design
that's basically identical to the iPhone
10r with a notch face ID and of course
removal of the home button now all of
that sounds nice but here's the big
issue it's supposed to be coming out in
2024 and by that time the entire iPhone
lineup will have already gotten rid of
the notch completely and switched over
to the dynamic Island design which is
happening next year with the iPhone 15
lineup so the Dilemma for apple is that
switching to the newer iPhone 10r design
is likely going to make it more
expensive but who in their right mind
would be buying a phone with a notch in
2024 and on top of that Apple would
likely have to withhold other features
like macsafe which of course wasn't
present in the iPhone 10r anyway and
that is the issue issue right there the
iPhone SC was originally supposed to be
a throwback to a smaller classier design
for those who didn't like the larger
iPhone 6 design but now everyone's
gotten used to larger phones and just
this year the 14 pro Max was actually
the best selling model out of the entire
lineup so basically the iPhone SC has
now become something totally different
it uses an outdated design that no one
really likes anymore and the feature set
is Cherry Picked by Apple to
intentionally hold back important
features so that the SE doesn't
cannibalize the sales of the higher end
models that basically makes the task of
creating a successful iPhone SE model
almost impossible since apple is trying
to make it worse on purpose and that
never works it's why I think the current
iPhone SE is a bad phone they kept the
design exactly the same again again
which was a huge disappointment and big
mistake in my opinion so for the iPhone
se4 it's going to be incredibly hard to
balance in terms of keeping the price as
low as possible without butchering the
features and value of the phone like
they did with the current iPhone SE
which is a terrible purchase right now
when you can simply buy a renewed iPhone
12 with the latest design right now for
just a bit more cash and honestly by the
time the iPhone se4 comes out the new 15
and 15 Pro Models are going to be coming
out with an even newer design which I
imagine could look something like these
renders and that of course will make the
SE design look even older so with that
said I believe that if Apple chooses to
delay the iPhone se4 I think it makes
more sense just to cancel it all
together or perhaps make it exclusive to
certain countries like India and others
where it makes sense to have a lower
priced iPhone but if you complete
greatly disagree with my thoughts in
this video then let me know down in the
comment section below and if you want to
see which iPhone I personally recommend
you buy right now check it out using the
YouTube product tagging feature and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video